but i don't think
you know
bad times are
gonna be around the corner permanently i
think temporary they're gonna be here
and it's gonna be ugly especially those
who are oblivious and they've spent too
much time watching netflix playing video
games spending too much time on tik tok
instagram yeah those guys i'm sorry you
paying the price because the news is
going to hit you 12 months later than
the people that are aware so you're
going to get hit very very hard but the
people that are actually the common
sense people here's what they're
noticing they're noticing
hypocrisy and contradictions for example
let me kind of go through this what's
wrong
with us
raising the age of somebody using an m16
to 25 years old
what's wrong with raising the age of
somebody using a gun at 21 years old
this is an 18 year old kid do you
realize when you're even in a military
even a soldier
us we can't keep the gun in our bed we
have to go put it in a place where they
keep it safe
sign it out it's not with me all the
time which they're right that's how i
was in the army okay yeah you have a
good point i'm sorry
oh but it's okay if a
eight-year-old kid wants to change their
sex
it's okay for us to give
the hormone medication where now they're
gonna make why i don't know if i'm a man
or oh you know what okay babe so so you
think
the 18 year old is not wise enough to
use a gun but you do think the 10 year
old is wise enough to
have a sex change okay so now you lose
because it's called hypocrisy
now you're contradicting yourself you
lose when you say it's my body my choice
and you go to lakewood church screaming
hollering getting naked half naked
taking your clothes off down to your
panties and your bra sports bra it's my
body my choice i can do whatever i want
to do with it okay cool that's all right
it's cool
uh listen man you know this vaccine
stuff
i mean my family's taking it i don't
want to take it let's just say no you
have to you're being irresponsible
that's contradiction okay so yeah let me
tell you it's the woman's choice when it
comes down to this okay but i have to
pay for it why do i have to i didn't
have the fun enjoyment that you had when
you had sex you enjoyed it i didn't
shiver you shook my toes didn't curl
your toes curled why am i having to pay
for
your toes curling i didn't get that
experience you got it okay
so so what is taking place today
is contradiction
on both sides are being revealed
and people are starting to say i read
between the bs bill maher is reading
between the bs fox news the other day
they're sitting there preaching all this
stuff about transgender they just did a
special on transgender i don't know if
you saw that or not the story that they
had on yeah i watched did you see it or
no i watched the did you watch the
special that they had where i've been
watching a lot of stuff from matt walsh
these days if you've seen what he's
putting out there with i am a woman or
have you ever seen any of this woman
what is a woman yeah fascinating yeah
but but what i'm saying is now fox fox
is putting it up it's kind of like well
so now fox is sitting there saying well
you know we got to go a little let's see
what the audience wants to hear so
your fox news
contradicting yourself and people are
sitting there saying what are you
pandering to so it doesn't matter which
way you go the average person is sitting
there saying i've never liked bill maher
but that just makes sense i've never
liked tucker carlson but that just makes
sense i've i just found out about joe
rogan i know hundreds of millions of
people listen to billions of views
online i found that because of what they
said and guess what i actually like what
the guy has to say this russell brand
guy isn't he supposed to be a full-on
left-wing you know a liberal guy this
guy makes sense people are starting to
say
hey
i i don't know i think there's a lot of
contradiction and they're they're going
to people who are able to reason and the
value the currency like you know how
hard work is a very valuable currency
right
respect is a very valuable currency okay
being able to reflect is a very valuable
currency right good attitude good
attitude very absolutely very valuable
currency loyalty very valuable currency
you know what people are starting to
realize is a very valuable currency the
ability to reason common sense wow you
want to hear something that's very
telling i was at the airport going
through security and we're going through
the machine right there's five women in
front of me and for some reason the
tsa guy says i need a male to come
through
so i said i qualify that is that okay
right crowded place everybody started
laughing
you know because they get it now if
there was maybe progressives there i
would have offended somebody and i even
said to him are you allowed to say that
he's come on through you know like that
but normal people are getting it so i
agree with what you're saying so you
know maybe this extreme
extremism that we're seeing that's
really caused a lot by the
you know i hate to say it because
and i want to ask you this question
about trump
this extremism
it's coming from the left i mean it's
coming from the far left i mean they're
the ones that put it out there they're
the ones that shout the loudest they're
the ones that do all of that and they
cause so much division in the country i
i really think it's coming from there
and i and i'm not picking on them i'm
just seeing it that's reality but this
extremism it's not what normal people
think they just don't think that way so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]